[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the newest iphone it's a couple
months later and this is the review
[Music]
so believe it or not this phone is about
four months old already which means a
lot of you considering buying one have
already made up your mind on that but
you definitely learn a lot from using a
phone for a longer period of time four
months isn't even that long it's just
longer than i usually take to review
things but for me at least you know with
four months you know this the honeymoon
period is over it's not brand new and
shiny anymore got your fingerprints on
it you got your scratches on it you've
used it every day and you really get to
know it best so first and foremost even
though this is the iphone 7 even though
this is supposed to be the bigger step
forward in the tick tock of apple
releases 6 6s
7 7s this is still definitely a very
familiar and very incremental upgrade to
the previous iphone again it's a
familiar iphone same rectangle with the
rounded corners for the design same big
forehead and chin with the home button
same seamless unibody metal industrial
design again and same scrolling pages of
icons for ios so at its core it's super
easy to get used to especially when
you're coming from another iphone just
to pick up an iphone 7. but that being
said there are plenty of little things
and plenty of refinements that all add
up to make a much better phone than you
had last year so on the outside the
improvements are more minor you know a
little design tweak from last year the
antenna bands are gone and the back
looks a little bit cleaner but it's
definitely still an iphone there's no
mistaking that so if you want to mess
with the design a little bit more you
can maybe put a skin on it like i showed
in my daily driver video but this design
as stale as it may seem is iconic and
very familiar so we still have some of
the biggest bezels in any smartphone
that is a bit annoying when you have the
white bezels
but that's so you can still have this
home button for at least one more year
and speaking of the home button it's now
not a physical button anymore but it's
more of like a force touch track pad it
doesn't actually move it's just a still
piece of glass but it's pressure
sensitive so when you press it it works
and the taptic motor makes a click and
it makes it feel like you're pressing a
button and it's really convincing i'd
say it's really easy to get used to it
used to be weird when you're like
pushing on a cable and you know it
doesn't really work with gloves but i'm
100 used to it now i'm actually totally
cool with this home button i should also
mention i think touch id is at the holy
grail where it's like a no-brainer
whether you should use it or not you set
it up once right when you get your phone
and it's faster and more secure than
typing in a password every single time
so i like touch id a lot anyway aside
from just the home button this is the
second generation of the iphone with 3d
touch but i don't really use it that
much i mean it's definitely built into
more apps and their shortcuts on the
home screens and even in the apps
themselves but
yeah i just don't really use it that
much one thing i do have to say though
is something the iphone doesn't get
enough credit for the iphone has the
best vibration motor in any smartphone
period and i'm talking about the taptic
engine like this phone literally feels
like it's tapping you on the wrist or in
your pocket or in your hand when you get
a notification it's awesome so i love
the taptic engine it's really good and
apple clearly knows this because they're
using it in way more parts of ios
animations now so like the notification
shade bouncing off the bottom of the
screen that type of thing or control
center bouncing up or really just any
bouncing anywhere in ios it always
clicks so the phone feels like it's
bouncing anyway one of the biggest
changes on the outside is it's now
officially a waterproof phone so the
iphone 7 is ip67 rated which means you
don't have to worry about dropping it in
or near water anymore and you can just
take underwater photos and videos if you
want basically the phone should survive
water exposure now but other than that
you know the displays on the iphone 7
are still pretty good you know nothing
crazy or amazing still has great color
reproduction uh but the one thing that's
killing me and it's not just me it's
tons of people obviously about the
outside of the phone is the lack of a
headphone jack basically apple is
clearly aiming for an entirely portless
wireless iphone in their future so in
that process they're removing the
headphone jack and starting to push
wireless audio super aggressive
yes
uh super forward thinking yes
uh super a pain in the ass also yes i
mean i think it's i'm probably gonna
make a whole video on the whole wireless
phone thing maybe let me know if you'd
want that in the comments section now
the camera on the iphone 7 is new too
you can see the different housing
there's a new sensor and new glass and
you might remember from the smartphone
awards this camera is already one of the
best it takes great photos and great 4k
videos i think it might get the title of
best low light photo camera back it was
kind of close with samsung but the image
processing from apple has always been
excellent autofocus is also extremely
fast and daytime photos look pretty damn
good too but it's by far the best video
camera in any smartphone i'll tell you
that right now i'll link below the video
i shot entirely on this camera but
seriously the 4k video from this sensor
with the optical image stabilization and
the big wide open aperture honestly
sometimes you can't tell the difference
from like a real dedicated mirrorless
camera's footage it's that good get a
little depth of field going i mean it's
awesome everything's there now the
iphone 7 plus has a second camera lens
as you already saw in my daily driver
video one regular camera same as the
smaller phone and one telephoto lens at
twice the focal length for that two
times optical zoom and it's really
interesting the way it works but i think
it turned out to be one of apple's
coolest products of 2016 last year
basically when you're all the way zoomed
out you're not just getting data from
the main camera as you would expect but
it's also actually intelligently using
some imagery stitching in from the
telephoto camera as well to make it a
little bit sharper and a little bit more
detailed in the center of the frame now
sometimes it uses lots of that data
sometimes none at all like if you
accidentally cover the telephoto lens
with your finger for example it doesn't
use anything from it but when you start
to zoom in a bit it continuously
intelligently analyzes how much of the
information to stitch in and then you
can actually see it completely switch
over cameras when you get to 2x zoom
it's subtle but the tiny changing
exposure is there you can see it and
from what i've seen it actively does
this switching during video recording
too so dual cameras is pretty awesome
and it works really well you can only
get it obviously on the bigger iphone
which is why i guess a lot of people
don't get to play with it but through
software updates stuff like portrait
mode is getting better every day and so
basically if you're into photography or
videography the iphone 7 plus is the
phone to get now on the inside basically
all you need to know that's changed is
the chip the a10 fusion chip is
fantastic in this phone and i'm pretty
comfortable calling this the most
responsive phone ever like this is
something apple does really well since
they control both all the hardware and
all the software so no phone is as
smooth and as one-to-one responsive to
the touch of your finger
as a fresh iphone i'd say the google
pixel comes closest right now and then
maybe the oneplus 3t right after that
and generally stock android phones but
the smoothness and high frame rates of
animations are the most consistent on
the iphone 7 and that's something i
really like and it's something you'll
appreciate like every single day you're
using the phone overall performance is
awesome through multitasking and
everyday use and gaming and navigation
and all kinds of stuff and the battery
life to go with that is also about the
same as last year which is to say pretty
good but not great so the iphone 7 has
an okay battery and decent standby time
while the bigger iphone 7 plus that i'd
recommend has pretty good battery with
excellent standby time also fun fact
this year apple made the iphone the same
dimensions
and included a bigger battery instead of
making it smaller with the same size
battery thank you apple keep doing that
please i really don't need it to be
thinner but that is pretty much what's
good with the new iphone lots of little
upsides lots of little improvements with
the hardware on the outside and on the
inside my biggest complaints would be
that they went with lightning over usb
type c again although i would totally
expect them to keep doing that and that
they went with no headphone jack instead
of
a headphone jack obviously i can't tell
you how many uber drivers have offered
me the aux cable and i have to turn down
the jams so at the end of the day iphone
7 has a lot that's new with it but
obviously it's still a very familiar
incremental upgrade just like previous
iphones have been and that's kind of the
point that's why people keep getting
iphones that's not a bad thing that's a
great reason to buy this phone again
especially if you're coming from a
previous gen but i think that this year
you're going to see a lot more big
improvements with the 10th generation
iphone or the iphone 7s or the iphone x
whatever they end up calling it that's
the one i'm most excited for until then
that's been it thank you for watching
and talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]